[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire y at il une menace fasciste
aujourd'hui en france certains pensent
considérant l'extrême droite isation de
la pensée actuelle les critiques
répétées de l'état de droit la défiance
à l'égard de la démocratie
représentative
les inégalités qui se creusent la
panique identitaire le racisme qui
montrent la peur du terrorisme la
sécurité qui est devenue plus importante
que la liberté la contestation sociale
les risques pandémiques la crise
environnementale
nos dirigeants seraient amenés à devenir
de plus en plus autoritaire avec le
risque de se retrouver un jour dans un
régime fasciste ou fascisant est ce que
c'est ce chemin que nous prenons depuis
ce début de xxième siècle pour en
débattre nous avons invité julien dames
11 est sociologue professeur associé à
sciences po est l'auteur d'une vingtaine
de livres sur la boîte pauvreté la
protection sociale les deux derniers
sont qui dort dehors aux éditions de
l'aube et la question sdf aux presses
universitaires de france alors vous avez
lu le livre de ludivine bantigny et et
de hugo pas l'état face à la menace
fasciste
hugues oppel et un est en retard
j'aurais dû lui poser la question
d'abord à lui et il est en retard je
vous la pose à vous est ce que ça vous a
convaincu es ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'il ya véritablement une
menace fasciste aujourd'hui ma réponse
est non en fait il aurait fallu poser la
question à celui qui aurait pu exposer
son topo je veux bien prendre son topo
général que je résumerais en disant que
la fascisation puisque c'est le hermes
qui l'emploie et contenu dans le
capitalisme et que la tendance actuelle
avec macron avec darmanin et cetera et
cetera consiste à aller vers un
gouvernement plus autoritaire alors ils
ne disent pas que macro ou darmanin sont
fascistes mais ils sont là en train de
nous expliquer que à terme pourrait
arriver des gouvernements toujours plus
autoritaire liberticide et ne voit deux
solutions à tout cela d'ailleurs comme
ça une gigantesque révolution alors moi
je suis pas du tout convaincu parce que
j'estime qu'au contraire les libertés
sont de plus en plus
élevé en france que la tolérance est
beaucoup plus élevé il met en avant le
fait que dans votre propos introductif
voulait ok les inégalités exploserait au
moins progressait ce qui est très court
se creuse secret de kells inégalités en
parle mais en fait en réalité elles sont
plutôt stables pour avoir des bagarres
de chiffres si vous le souhaitez le
mamers
adhérents tout cela on en conclut que
voilà dans les considérant comme on
dirait dans un texte juridique en effet
ils aboutissent à une conclusion assez
forte qui est de dire que nous allons
vers un régime qui pourrait devenir
correspondant ils ont quand même une
rigueur dans les mots ou un qui a pu
être baptisé fascistes dans le premier
mot c'est de dire que sur les inégalités
c'est très discutable on a l'impression
que il ya la mise à bas de l'état social
en france ça n'est pas vrai la france
est toujours championne du monde des
dépenses sociales la deuxième chose sur
le racisme la france n'est pas plus
raciste que d'autres pays et puis
surtout elle l'est bien moins qu'elle a
pu l'être si on prend la période de
louis de funès et du gendarme et les
gendarmettes il faut voir si vous ne
l'avez pas vu depuis longtemps ce qu'est
la position du brave gendarme cruchot
lorsqu'il s'aperçoit que parmi les cinq
gendarmes est il y à une noire si
quelqu'un a osé faire ça dans un film et
bien que cruelle et tous les personnages
de louis de funès y compris dans rabbi
jacob sont toujours des personnages de
raciste à l'ancienne ouais et c'est
justement ce qui nous faisait rire oui
et ça ça nous faisait rire etc mais ça
dénotait je pense cet exemple parce que
c'est lui qui me vient à l'esprit une
période de l'histoire où la tolérance
était bien moins élevées à l'égard de
populations qui n'était pas
traditionnellement en france de mai pour
le duo de façon plus simple
je pense que là les français sont bien
moins raciste qu'auparavant et c'est pas
moi qui le pense c'est que si on regarde
les enquêtes valeurs qui sont faites
tous les dix ans depuis 40 ans si on
regarde les sondages d'opinion
barométrique les français déclarent de
moins en moins que vivre à côté de
personnes qui seraient gitane musulmane
homosexuel serait problématique qu'il ya
je trouve quelque chose de très
contestable dans l'analyse qui consiste
dans les constats à dire bah oui l'état
providence s'effondre il ya des attaques
radicale des néolibéraux des
capitalistes en forme et l'engin un peu
touche un peu vache parce qu'il n'est
pas là pour désordre à notre jeu
j'estime que l'on peut avoir une
discussion tout à fait pu poser l'adci
jamais dans les constats c'est
discutable sur l'effondrement supposé
d'état social et les ac l attaque l
égard de l'endroit à l'encontre de
l'état social et sur la tolérance et ses
faux enfin voilà alors qu' il y ait une
droitisation transition je pense que
c'est assez incontestable alors on doit
la voir dans un autre contexte qu'une
forme 2d droitisation du rassemblement
national c'est ce que critique je pense
le patriarche le pen alors à l'égard de
sa fille le front national se normalise
alors ça ils estiment dans leur ouvrage
que c'est un déguisement pour faire
passer leur message mais le fait qu'il
pourrait y avoir des droitisation du
front national et le moins en moins
d'extrême droite et de fait qui candidat
aujourd'hui à la collection
présidentielle déclaré à droite bah oui
demande davantage d'autorité plus de
rigueur en matière de lutte contre
l'immigration de là à appeler ça de
l'extrême droite et de la appeler ça du
fascisme y'a pas un pas il ya un océan à
mon sens bon vous l'avez compris moi je
suis dans la situation que redoute tous
les animateurs de télévision et de radio
ouais c'est que vous êtes en direct et
que votre invité n'est pas là je peux
vous faire une proposition
oui je change de sièges quand il défend
la thèse adverse mais moi mais non mais
il va pas tarder c'est sûr enfin c'était
c'est vrai que c'est tous les animateurs
se disent forcément ça va m'arriver à
jour avait vu sa peine arrivé déjà deux
fois mais le voilà voilà et voyez c'est
au moment où on commence à en parler que
généralement ils arrivent hugo pas
l'état bienvenus
alors je vous présente vous êtes
sociologue maître de conférences en
sciences de l'éducation à l'université
lille iii vous êtes l'auteur de la
possibilité du fascisme qui était paru à
la découverte en 2018 et vous voulez
publier chez textuel avec l'historienne
ludivine bantigny qui était d'ailleurs à
6 à votre place sur un autre sujet il
n'ya pas longtemps
face à la menace fasciste un livre dans
lequel vous ne dites pas que nous sommes
en france à l'heure actuelle dans un
régime fasciste mais bon leur est quand
même grave il ya un processus favorisant
l'accès des fascistes au pouvoir tout en
créant les conditions de la construction
d'un état fasciste
est-ce que vous pouvez nous résumer en
trois en trois phrases
votre position sachant que je viens
vient déjà de la réfuter il est dit
qu'il n'était pas d'accord après avoir
lu votre livre mais justement s'ils
pouvaient de la résumer puisqu'on va en
parler pendant toute l'émission très
rapidement la thèse du livre aller
simple macron s'est fait élire en se
présentant comme un barrage ont un
rempart à l'extrême droite et la vérité
des prix d'une certaine manière c'est la
montée en puissance en france mais c'est
un phénomène effectivement international
de l'extrême droite sur le plan
électoral avec marine le pen annoncé au
tour en collision entre 40 et 50% au
deuxième tour si elle est présente de
l'élection présentielle en 2022 et une
montée en puissance également
idéologique avec l'omniprésence de
discours d'extrême droite d obsession
identitaire nationaliste xénophobe
islamophobe
de l'extrême droite dans des médias de
grande écoute alors j'imagine qu'on
développera mais il ya plusieurs
mécanismes là il ya à la fois la
continuité des politiques de destruction
sociale qui sont en général associé au
néolibéralisme démantèlement des
services publics
disons effritement du code du travail
et de la sécurité sociale également qui
crée du désespoir de la désespérance
notamment dans les classes populaires
mais pas seulement dans les couches
intermédiaires aussi et puis il ya le
fait pour les gouvernements et en
particulier le gouvernement de macron de
chasse est systématiquement sur les
terres de l'extrême droite sur à la fois
sur le plan des politiques qui sont
menées je pense à la loi sécurité
globale et à la loi dite séparatiste
mais aussi sur le plan des discours avec
de la reprise telle quelle d'expression
issu de l'extrême droite gérard collomb
début du quinquennat parlant de
submersion migratoire par exemple et
d'oïl et bien d'autres choses et puis
enfin il ya géré le troisième élément
c'est la disqualification systématique
par ce gouvernement ont par exemple jean
michel blanquer
frédéric vidal de la gauche dès gauche
des mouvements sociaux au nom du fait
qu'il serait complice par exemple de
l'islamisme du terrorisme de du
racialisme d'antisémitisme et c est donc
finalement c'est une manière de bloquer
toute alternative de gauche au
néolibéralisme et d'une certaine manière
c'est une manière de de présenter
l'extrême droite que nous nous
qualifions pour l'essentiel de nouveaux
fascistes comme la seule le seul
opposant légitime d'une certaine manière
à macron ça ce serait le processus de
fascisation qui serait actuellement à
l'oeuvre en france pour l'essentiel avec
des traites qui sont des traits qui sont
très inquiétants un en particulier
quelque chose sur lequel on insiste
c'est sur le plan pas simplement des
discours donc idéologique mais aussi sur
le plan des pratiques et de
notamment de ce qui se joue dans les
appareils de répression de l'état bon de
la police et notamment tous les marges
de manoeuvre qui sont de plus en plus
laisser à la police pour faire un peu ce
qu'elle veut un bon on a vu des
policiers manifester
appelés par leurs syndicats devant
l'assemblée nationale pour faire
pression sur les parlementaires certains
d'ailleurs hommes politiques ont parlé
de manifestations factieuses je pense
que ce que c'est le cas on a vu des
remous aussi dans l'armée avec des
tribunes assez largement signé un on
sent que quelque chose se passe du côté
de ces appareils de répression qui qui
en quelque sorte peut préparer
l'avènement d'un régime tout autrement
autoritaire que ce à quoi on fait face
aujourd'hui qui est déjà une manière
très brutalisé de par exemple de
maintenir l'ordre ce que montrait par
exemple des sociologues comme fabien
jobard olivier fille dans un livre
récent qui nous a sans doute pas échappé
qui parle de brutalisation du maintien
de l'ordre dans les dernières années
notamment on va dire depuis le milieu
des années 2000 10 1 la loi travail
c'est terrible ce processus
vous vous le contester oui de réserve
d'avoir sur de gros élément du constat
sur l'effritement de l'état social et
puis sur la brutalisation de la police
sur l'effritement de l'état social dans
vos trouvailles qui a pas un chiffre en
europe à faire une avalanche de chiffres
mais la france est toujours le pays qui
a la part de pipe affectés à la
protection sociale qui est le plus élevé
retrouvez plein de petits exemples à
regarder macron à
grappillé 5 euros d'apl etc mais c'est
ça qui est passé dans le débat public en
même temps vous avez eu des réductions
de loyer de solidarité pour les
locataires hlm ca sommes neutres pour
mettons de côté la question du logement
sur laquelle donne vous dit un mot au
total sur toute la période macro nien et
notamment depuis la crise coville on n'a
jamais autant dépensé vous dites coup de
canif ou pire un coup de canon contre le
droit du travail je veux bien mais
lesquels ce qui est dans votre ouvrage
c'est quelques petites remarques sur les
possibilités de se séparer en matière de
droit du travail et en matière de
contrats sans passer par un contentieux
compliqué il faut ça très bien les
ruptures conventionnelles
la personne qui va dire parmi celles qui
y sont passés peut-être y at-il un temps
de petits contentieux dans les
prud'hommes mais au total ça se passe
très bien donc je trouve extrêmement
réfutable constat selon lequel l'état
social si free chaque année nous
dépensons davantage en matière de
protection sociale les interros parce
que ça c'est un sujet qui m'a toujours
intéressé je me dis que même si vous
aviez raison et vous avez peut-être
raison
le ressenti le ressenti de la population
étant exactement inverse au fond ça ne
compte pas c'est à dire que kantari
hitler arrive au pouvoir il dit à la
population allemande que les juifs sont
les maîtres de l'économie allemande ce
qui est faux mais les allemands le
croient et ils sont ils en sont même
peut-être persuadé avant même qu'il
arrive au pouvoir et donc l'effet est le
même que si ça avait été vrai alors par
rapport à hitler il ya plein de
différence vous à une importante qui
n'est pas le majeur de même ce qui est
pas de sondages d'opinion à l'époque on
ne savait pas ce que pensaient les gens
on ne savait pas ce qu'était exactement
la part de la dépense publique affecter
en l'espèce à la protection sociale ou à
la police etc etc donc le débat public
était un peu moins bien armés
aujourd'hui il l'est mais je suis comme
vous je suis d'accord il ya un décalage
entre ce que les gens perçoivent et ceux
qui se trouvent dans les statistiques de
même sur la pauvreté sur les inégalités
ça fait des années qu'on entend dire que
la pauvreté explose que les inégalités
explosent du point de vue du ressenti
tout ceci pour se retrouver les français
sont les plus inquiets dans l'occident à
l'égard de la possibilité de tomber dans
la pauvreté le taux de pauvreté est
stable alors on peut contester sa les
indicateurs quand ils ne conviennent pas
mais ma première réserve sur les
constats qui vous amène à faire ses
remarques ses observations puis ces
propositions de révolution eh bien je
pense que c'est seulement discutable
c'est contestable et parfois faux
deuxième mot sur la police mais moi je
veux bien me faire le sociologue
défenseur de la police et des forces de
l'ordre la brutalisation de la police
pourquoi pas la brutalisation du
maintien de l'ordre jobard filiale aux
caisses et des références de sociologues
c'est d'abord la brutalisation de la
société moi quand j'ai été invité à
l'émission j'ai pensé que ce que l'on
dirait c'est que ce sont les mouvements
sociaux qui sont de plus en plus
fasciste non mais vraiment je pensais
qu'on allait dire les gilles et jo j'ai
pour lui dire vous
savez gilet jaune sur le nouvelle
chemise brune balaou et chemise vert
parce que c'est un mouvement fasciste à
la française de monsieur de deux
danseurs danjer voilà danger parce que
vous êtes spécialiste que moi sur les
mouvements fascistes mais pour être plus
précis je trouve que dire que la police
aujourd'hui tu as tout le monde la
violence policière c'est insupportable
c'est oublier que la police est de plus
en plus agressés donc vingt mille
policiers et gendarmes ont été blessés
alors après ça en une année ce 20007
aussi en prenant en considération ceux
qui se sont blessés sur leur plan de
transport etc mais c'est deux fois plus
qu'il ya une quinzaine d'années les
commissariats sont attaqués les
gendarmeries également choses assez
extraordinaire je ne sais pas si ça
existe ailleurs en occident ce n'est pas
la police mais les pompiers aussi
parfois sont attaqués donc oui de temps
en temps il est nécessaire que la police
se protège et ce pour une bonne raison
c'est pour nous protéger donc je conclus
pour le débat qui peuvent sans être vif
être assez fondamental je suis en
désaccord total avec d'autres vos
constats essentielles qui sont de dire
que l'état social s'effrite et la police
est de plus en plus brutale inutilement
donc c'est la guerre sociale dont parle
dont paris la livre le tom garcia
l'étude il pourrait nous disons à 2
alors je réponds sur les deux points sur
la police d'abord si on regarde les
chiffres par exemple les morts 2
policiers dans l'exercice de leur métier
assez de manière assez conséquente
baissé depuis les années 80
donc bien sûr tant mieux d'une certaine
manière mais surtout si on rapporte à la
population de policiers qui n'est pas
stable dans le temps
la deuxième chose que je dirais c'est ce
qui est assez hallucinant dans
l'augmentation
des chiffres c'est c'est le traitement
est ahurissant réservé au gilet jaune
qui n'était pas un mouvement fasciste du
tout qui était une mobilisation sociale
de gens qui réclamait plus de pouvoir
d'achat etc bombay qui ont subi la
répression la plus la plus ahurissante
dans l'histoire sociale française depuis
des décennies mille prise peines de
prison ferme y de centaines de prison
avec sursis 25 personnes qui ont perdu
un oeil
quatre à cinq personnes qui ont perdu
une main une femme tuée par un tir de
gaz lacrimogène femme de 80 ans siné
brédois à marseille bon c'est tout ça
c'est du jamais vu dans l'histoire
sociale française depuis des décennies
pour un mouvement qui par ailleurs
numériquement n'était pas le plus
important des 20 dernières années loin
de là donc rapporter à la au nombre de
gens qui se sont mobilisés c'était
quelques centaines de milliers de
personnes le mouvement contre la réforme
des retraites en 2010 était plusieurs
millions à huit ou neuf reprises ce que
je veux dire c'est que mon hebdomadaire
ce que montrent et sociologue
spécialiste de ce type de question c'est
qu'il ya bien eu un changement de
doctrine et de pratiques du maintien de
l'ordre beaucoup plus au contact des
manifestants est par ailleurs là on
parle de gens mutilés on parle pas de
vitrines cassées ou là donc la violence
qu'on assimile haut que l'autre on
m'associe aux manifestants en général
c'est des vitrines moi c'est pas le mode
d'action dont je pense qu'il permet
d'obtenir une transformation sociale
mais il n'empêche ce n'est pas la même
chose que des violences faites aux
individus aux personnes des personnes je
disais une trentaine de personnes qui
ont été mutilés au cours de ce mouvement
c'est celle là encore comment vous avez
l'inédit comment l'expliquez-vous dans
ce cas là c'est parce que le
gouvernement a peur c'est essayer je
pense que nous défendons dans dans ce
livre c'est qu'il ya une triste
d'hégémonisme à une difficulté de plus
en plus grande et des gouvernements qui
se succèdent à obtenir le consentement
d'une large majorité de la population
aux politiques elles mènent bon c'est à
dire que au bout de trente ans les
politiques néolibérales qui nous disent
bon libéralisent le marché du travail on
taxe - les riches en taxes au moins les
entreprises devront l'impôt sur le
bénéfice des sociétés ça ne vous aura
pas échappé a énormément baissé depuis
les années 90
et ça va réussir les sur nous sur les
salariés et c'est bon tout le monde peut
constater que ça ne ce n'est pas le cas
il ya cinq millions de chômeurs au bas
mot dans ce pays trois millions plus 2
millions qui sont des cookies qui ceux
qui voudraient travailler mais qui sont
considérés comme inactifs
si si by ya trois millions de chômeurs 3
2 millions de personnes en bus qui
veulent travailler davantage aimerait
travailler avant par louis qui travaille
parfois quelques heures dans la semaine
et c'est qu'ils ont des revenus 2 misait
et qui voudraient travailler qu'ils sont
découragés souvent même d'ailleurs qui
sont radiées des institutions de
l'emploi et septembre donc
voilà alors sur l'autre point qui était
celui des et celui de la casse sociale
vous oubliez la réforme des retraites
qui a été stoppée du fait de la séquence
qu'ovide vous oubliez la réforme de
l'assurance chômage mais manu macron a
annoncé récemment que ces réformes
allaient sans doute eu reprendre donc si
je vous suis à rien n'a été cassé
puisque vous citez de réformes qui n'ont
pas été mises en place oui mais c'est
beau c'est le projet de le faire et 2
sanaa ça n'a été que suspendu par
ailleurs sur le code du travail on lui
applique associé à la sauce que sap a
été mis en place oui mais le risque
c'est que dans l'année qui vient puisque
ça a été annoncé par emmanuel macron
vous pouvez pas dire que c'est pas dans
le projet des mêmes raconte le projet ma
chronique est un projet de démantèlement
de par exemple du système de retraite
par répartition c'est une idée folle
qu'est
un mot dans la réforme pour parler de
leurs vertus c'est pas des attaquants
face
à des dates sur l'économie française sur
le droit du travail la loi travail de
2016 est un vous me dites c'est pas un
bruit il n'y a pas écoutés c'est un coup
de canif et c'était l'équipe hollande
valls et macron c'est une loi macron ça
a été appelée la loi est le bris mais
hugues oppel état je voudrais qu'on
comprenne en quoi ça par exemple tout ce
que vous décrire peu importe le que vous
ne soyez pas d'accord en quoi sa phase
iib fait ça facilite tout ça favorise
l'accès des fascistes au pouvoir puisque
c'est ça le processus parce que si on
vous le verrez sur le long terme en fait
bon d'abord il faut préciser que le type
de projet politique et le fascisme c'est
un nationalisme et ultra-autoritaire
ethniciste racialiste ne se développe
que dans des situations de crise sociale
importante à
ou quand on a une forme de désespérance
de masse de défiance vis-à-vis des
gouvernements traditionnelle et c'est
bon plusieurs décennies ont produit
finalement ce type de défiance et de
désespérance dans une situation qu'il ya
deux éléments il ya cette désespérance
qui se combine à la destruction des
solidarités collectives titre disons
antérieurement était associé au mundo ce
qu'on appelle le mouvement ouvrier la
gauche ou le parti communiste la cgt etc
produisez du collectif produisent et une
espérance collective produisait aussi
l'idée que c'était possible d'aller vers
une autre société bon ça a été en grande
partie brisée au cours du processus mais
au libéral donc à partir des années 80
donc ça combiné à la désespérance
sociale c'est un cocktail terrible et
effectivement dans ce type de situation
où la gauche n'apparaît plus comme une
alternative et où les gouvernements du
centre de ce que nous appelons l'extrême
centre se délégitime parler politique
qu'il mène ce délégitime auprès des
classes populaires en particulier et de
la jeunesse et bien l'extrême droite
peut apparaître comme une force comme
une alternative fausse de mon point de
vue évidemment il peut apparaître comme
une force contre hégémonique 1 et
aujourd'hui et la force contre hégémonie
dominante en france c'est le front
national rassemblement national
aujourd'hui comme malheureusement les
lettres peuvent l'être des organisations
d'extrême droite dans d'autres pays vous
sujet bien qu'on peut prix julie adam on
vous pensez pas à la fois que sa
fabrique
du vote d'extrême droite ni même une
extrême droite isation de la pensée et
encore moins de la pensée de nos
gouvernants
nombre
extrême droite néo libéralisme hégémonie
ben ça c'est plein de grands mots
néolibéralisme depuis les années 80
notamment du côté des sociologues et des
spécialistes de sciences politiques on
entend ça et on lit ça depuis des années
mais qu'appelle-t-on néolibéralisme par
une faune en général voir bibliographie
très bien mais si on regarde ce qu'est
la progression de la collectivisation si
vous voulez ce à quoi vous pourriez
prêter attention de l'appareil productif
de la dépense publique etc nous sommes
dans un pays où la majorité de la
dépense est une dépense publique sommes
dans un pays dont le président gérard
car des stores et puis il est un pays
communiste regard de ce qu'il avait dit
quand les années 70 ce pays communiste
donc maintenant il y avait commises
parce qu'on peut aller jusqu'à 100% mais
c'est ce que vous pourriez proposez vous
dans votre rupture avec je suis amusé
président giscard en faisant il avait
dit à partir de 40 pour demain vivement
on est à 50 cent est dans une société
socialiste oui oui mais il avait pas 10
40% prélèvements une vie 40 % de
dépenses on a plus de 40 % de dépenses
on est à 56 % parce qu on s'endette et
c'est beaucoup plus après la crise qu
vide qui n'a pas été traité par un
gouvernement fasciste ou fascisant pour
pour la dépense la dépense lors de la
dépense publique
extrêmement amer parce que donc tout
votre analyse ensuite dans la rhétorique
on va dire il ya les méchants ni aux
libéraux il ya le néolibéralisme en
marche et je pense que c'est un fantasme
sur les indicateurs que vous utilisez de
part des dépenses sociales dans le pib
est de par des prélèvements je pense que
ce sont des mots de mauvais indicateurs
ont rejeté ce sont de gros chiffres de
gros indicateurs il faut regarder qui
est axé bon de fait les plus riches sont
beaucoup moins taxés aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne l'étaient dans les années 80
d'ailleurs c'est un phénomène mondial je
vais pas renvoyer aux travaux de piketty
mai et à son équipe mais c'est une et
vous critiquez d'ailleurs il dit
d'ailleurs louis s'est tu pour d'autres
questions mais c'est une évidence et
d'autre part il ya la question de
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des impôts par
exemple quand on fait 20 milliards ou 30
milliards de cice sa manette une
réduction d'impôt ses mérites sais-tu ce
sont des exonérations de cotisations
sociales vous savez ce que ça représente
20 à 30 milliards d'euros aussi l'état
angolais
s'il était encore combien d'emplois au
salaire moyen c'est près d'un millier on
doit immédiatement combien a créé
l'exploit à peu près 110 g pour faire
des policiers moi ça me donne à west et
pour créer des postes dans la santé dans
un service public de la petite enfance
de jésus troisième dealers du quartier
du quatrième âge de il ya des besoins
non satisfaits dans toute une série de
secteurs que devrait prendre en charge
de l'état l'état plutôt que j'aime c'est
de donner à fond perdu sans aucune aucun
engagement aucune contrepartie de la
part du patronat on se souvient qu'ils
avaient promis un million d'emplois avec
des pin's d'ailleurs un bon ça n'est
jamais arrivé moi ya eu cent mille
emplois selon les estimations
économétriques bon c'est la vérité des
prix là encore on aurait mis ces 20
milliards d'euros sur le cce il y aurait
eu on aurait pu créer des centaines de
milliers d'emplois dans des secteurs qui
en ont dramatiquement besoin que vous
pensez que ces néo libérale que d'avoir
dépensé 200 milliards d'euros en plus
c'est à dire 10 points de pib pour
contrer la crise qu vite que nous avons
traversé les est ce que le chômage
partiel qui a été à disposition que
générer parmi les plus généreux est un
dispositif néolibérale fait tous les
gouvernements boris johnson en
angleterre en décembre dispersion trump
hayden et c'est les méchants vous mettez
en avant ils ont fait ça mais pas cette
année au lycée ce sont des idées des
états qui vise à maintenir l'activité
c'est normal d'une certaine manière ce
sont des états capitalistes ils ne
souhaitaient pas que l'économie
capitaliste et fonde donc ils ont fait
des politiques qu'ils auraient
évidemment à bord et cinq ou dix ans
auparavant simplement la situation de
leur point de vue qu'au prix d'un
maintien de l'activité de production et
donc de production de profits impliqué à
ce moment précis de faire ce type de
politique ce sont des gens qui sont qui
s'avoue et l'heure où est leur intérêt
par contre ils sont à maquereau est
revenu à l'idée des réformes de
structure néolibérale il est donc clair
qu'il vaut mieux l'idéal je la région de
là je vous laisserai pas faire à des
bals fait le guet au libéralisme
revanche puisque l'on essaie agréé vu
que vides on pourrait dire aussi que
les mesures qui ont été prises par
l'état français ont été les plus
liberticides qu'aucun fasciste n'avais
jamais rêvé alors d'enfermer les gens
ils en avaient rêvé il personne de la
veille par dire d'aller enterrer leurs
morts était de ceux délivrés soit même
des autorisations de sortir que pouvez
vérifier les policiers dans un rayon
d'un kilomètre autour de chez soi
reconnaissait que ça nous a préparés à
quelque chose ça c'est possible c'est
cet exode est d'ailleurs j'aurais même
une question vis-à-vis de votre analyse
c'est que vous n'en parlez pas de salade
x dictature sanitaires alors nous on
parlerait pas de dictature à l'inter
parce que ce sont des expressions que
nous n'employons pas parce que ce camp
pas moi que ce soit nous ont dit nous
dirons pas en dictature mais
mais il ya deux éléments là dedans
effectivement tout ce qui effectivement
au niveau presque individuelles haut
niveau même de nos affects et c'est peut
nous préparer à des régimes beaucoup
plus autoritaire que ce que nous avons
connu jusque là mais il ya la gestion
ultra autoritaire de la crise sanitaire
dont là on parle est extrêmement
verticale est extrêmement opaque avec un
parlement largement contournée
marginalisés dans cette affaire puisque
toutes les décisions sont prises pour
l'essentiel par le président on
conseille de défense ce qui est quand
même très très loin des standards on va
dire de la démocratie libérale ou ce
qu'on pourrait attendre d'une démocratie
libérale dont avec parfois deux bonnes
décisions comme par exemple de ne pas
avoir confiné lors de la deuxième vague
masson bon je vous interromps ont fait
une pause et après justement on va
s'intéresser avec nos libertés publiques
puisque elles sont paraît-il 2e plus en
plus réduite c'est ce que l'on va voir
[Musique]
à
combien s'élève la facture du quoi qu'il
en coûte comment va se mettre en place
le sur mesure qui n'est pas une fois
qu'on a dépensé des milliards des
centaines de milliards à arroser tout le
monde et à faire tenir des gens qui
n'auraient jamais dû tenir que
maintenant on va pouvoir se vanter de
faire un peu de sur mesure toute la
question c'est de parfaire aujourd'hui
l'erreur de 2011 qui avait été d'enlever
les mesures de soutien à l'économie
après la crise de 2008 beaucoup trop tôt
ce qui avait cassé la dynamique
économique de la reprise la déclaration
de bruno le maire il sait très bien que
le jeu il arrête c'est fini vous aurez
des sociétés typhon failli à ce qu'on
leur demandera de rembourser quelque
chose qu'elles ne peuvent pas rembourser
elle en était bien incapable déjà avant
de s'endetter et aujourd'hui elles ne
pourront pas c'est les chaises musicales
si vous voulez y aura pas assez de
chaises contre le monde
à la veille d'un procès historique le
procès des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
comment vous l'avez abordé je crois que
les victimes attendent de pouvoir
témoigner une exigence de vérité une
exigence de justice nous allons les
accompagner du début de la crise jusqu'à
leur reconstruction dantec ce soit
possible pour certaines on parle
beaucoup de l'accompagnement
psychologique mais il ya tout un champ
d'accompagnement autres et
l'indemnisation qui est extrêmement
importante pour ces personnes la
problématique va être quel prix va-t-on
assigné à la douleur quel prix vaut
votre fille quel prix votre père et
c'est impossible c'est un procès pour
les victimes c'est un procès également
pour la république il ne s'agit de rien
d'autre que de juger des hommes qui ont
commis un attentat sur le territoire qui
doivent être condamnés
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec hugo pas l'état
qui publie face à la menace fasciste
chez textuel avec l'historienne ludivine
montigny et julien dames ont tous les
deux donc son sociologue alors on s'est
intéressé à ce que vous appelez dans
votre livre le capitalisme autoritaire
j'aimerais qu'on regarde maintenant la
la réduction des libertés publiques
puisque ça aussi il en est très souvent
question pas seulement dans votre livre
d'ailleurs mais ça fait un certain
nombre d'années que à certain nombre de
gens constatent que nos libertés se
réduisent que le l'état de droit est
attaqué de tout bord alors est ce que
est ce que c'est le cas véritablement
puisque vous avez est ce que ce serait
ça qui favoriserait la construction n'a
d'état fasciste et des observations
assez convergentes de ce point de vue là
il ya des rapports qui ont été rendus
par amnesty international la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme des travaux plus scientifique ou
encore la demande d' enquête de michelle
bachelet quand elle était haut
commissaire aux droits de l'homme à
l'onu au moment du mouvement des gilets
jaunes sur autour de la répression du
niveau de répression donc bon il me
semble que le on pourrait parler
derrière de françois sureau aussi cet
avocat qui était plutôt proche de la
droite d'ailleurs un françois fillon et
macron d'ailleurs qui a écrit tout un
livre pour dire à quel point
les libertés publiques étaient remises
en cause et c'est notamment par la
guerre contre le terrorisme voilà c'est
à dire par l'empilement notamment de loi
anti terroriste par le transfert de loi
qui sont au départ présenté comme anti
casseurs mais à la gestion des des
manifestants et des mobilisations
sociales part on pourrait également
parler de l'armement des dits non létale
mais en réalité qui mutile et qui peut
tuer des policiers qui dans les études
montrent je pense là aux livres de paul
rocher que cet armement ça a
explosé au cours des dernières années
les policiers sont beaucoup plus doté en
armes qui peuvent qui peuvent se mutiler
notamment les flash ball ou non l bd etc
toute allusion à sébastian roché plus
exactement n'en démographie main je
pensais à paul rocher dans un excès
rebelles gaz et multi des soumettre
sortie je crois l'année dernière où il
ya deux ans donc il me semble que le que
le constat est assez état c'est
indéniable et effectivement on peut se
dire que il y à là les éléments on va
dire non pas idéologique mais matériel
de possibilité d'une fascisation de
l'état qui n'est qui n'est pas du tout
accompli à ce stade un loin de là mais
qui pourrait s'opérer dans une deuxième
phase notamment consécutive à l'arrivée
au pouvoir du d'un mouvement d'extrême
droite voilà je viens dans mon ouïe
le premier sujet c'est qu'est ce que
c'est que l'extrême droite dans votre
ouvrage reprenant ce qui se dit dans les
sphères de gauche on a droit à valeurs
actuelles mensuel d'extrême droite enfin
il ya une et vous allez bien mais oui
c'est évident même pour moi c'est
absolument pas évident l'extrême droite
donc peut-être va nous dire à côté
d'elle il y à une ultra droite vous la
trouvez dans d'autres journaux de type
rivarol réfléchir et agir ou là en effet
on a une rhétorique et des positions qui
ce n'est pas faire insulte à leur auteur
sont purement fascistes mais valeurs
actuelles un journal conservateur sans
qu'il y ait à mon sens appelle à la
création d'un régime fasciste vous ce
que vous dites c'est vous ne vous en
rendez pas compte mais nous progressons
lentement par le noeud lepénisation des
esprits termes que vous n'employez pas
avec était employé auparavant par une
fascisation lente tout ce qui est de
l'ordre du maintien de l'ordre c'est
fabien jobard que vous vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure avec une jolie formule il
disait que les crs ou les gendarmes
mobiles il ya une trentaine d'années à
côté des habits dont il dispose
aujourd'hui paraîtrait tout nu mais je
pense que c'est nécessaire on a
l'impression que c'est l'état et la
police l'appareil répressif d'étals
althusser que vous évoquiez en incise au
tout départ qui serait plus violent je
pense que ce sont les manifestants qui
sont plus violents moi j'ai les images
qui me viennent à l'esprit de policiers
et de gendarmes qui ont été molestés
frappé pour certains d'entre eux blessés
blessé gravement à la bataille des
chiffres ça servira parier à se réglera
rien ici est un choix à faire soit on
est côté du côté des manifestants qui
cassent tous sont des du côté de la
police disperse à préserver et qu'on ne
casse pas tout moi je suis du côté de la
police voyez dire c'est des grands
mouvements sociaux les casseurs ont été
provoqués etc mais dans le mouvement des
gilets jaunes il est plein de gens
extrêmement sympathique avec leur
barbecue sur les ronds points il y avait
des gens et il y en a de plus en plus
dans toutes les manifestations quelle
qu'elle soit qui viennent pour tout
casser si c'est pour casser du flic on
sait ce qu'on avait mis en garde les
compagnies pour aller dans le sens il
faut les protéger c'est que ça pourrait
aller dans le sens de la bonnasse
fasciste justement ça mais la manoeuvre
si ce n est plus du côté ce que je sais
ce que j'étais en train de vie autonome
et anti fascistes les antifas pour moi
une grande partie sont des fascistes
voilà
ça me je trouve ça sidérant de
dépolitisation serre que je vois pas au
nom de quoi les donc les antifascistes
qu'est-ce qu'ils qu'est ce qu'ils font
de fachos qui fléchit les mouvements
dits anti faxon les mouvements qu'on
trouve dans les manifestations anti sont
des mouvements
actuels qui appellent par tags ou par
après j'ai pas de discussions entre eux
et puis théorisation affaires d une
manifestation même violente contre la
police pas à câble écrit partout donc
une traduction hall qotsa or le kop sa
bastard et c'est tout ce que l'on trouve
la police et d'autres ennemis etc c'est
insupportable dans une société à l'heure
de plus vous un supporter que les les
mutilations dont j'ai parlé tout annonce
à
quelques unes en pâtit les 700 morts
sans que jamais d'ailleurs ou presque
jamais un policier ne soit ne soient
condamnés dans des quartiers populaires
ou des jeunes hommes en général noirs et
arabes ont été il ya eu un comptage à la
tv par bastamag il ya quelques quelques
années qui monte je crois 670 morts
depuis 40 ans à peu près 40 ans oui avec
une impunité policière presque constante
ça a pas l'air de la région que des
slogans comme acab ne vous semblent plus
choquant et scandaleux que des pratiques
qui aboutissent à la mutilation et à la
mort de masse qui me sentais les chocs
et dérangeants fait une serre de
choquant c'est les violences physiques
saône à l'endroit des solidarités avec
le fédéral mis des vitrines avec les
familles des vitres et vitrines oui oui
vous avez plus de solidarité avec les
femmes alimentaient la base il fascisme
c'est le tag alors c'est pas exactement
votre orientation là dessus c'est cette
idée selon laquelle l'autre on ne le
respecte pas donc on va aller
progressivement investir l'espace public
on va camper on va casser on va puisque
on manifeste on a droit à tout
pulvériser à l'attaqué la police je sais
pas si c'est le meilleur terme pour ça
mais ça me semble autoritaire ça me
semble dénier les droits des autres si
vous ne pouvez pas appeler ça fascistes
vous parce que ça correspond pas à ce
que vous mettez dans votre
enveloppe au laxisme pour laquelle sa
violence matérielle violences sur deux
sur des sur des sur des objets ce qu'est
ce que ça a à voir avec le racisme et le
fascisme c'est un projet politique or
d'accord très vieux rêve ya un projet
politique pas de tori nationaliste et
une voix autoritaire de purification de
la nation qu'est ce que ça avec le crac
excusez moi qu'est-ce que ça arrive à
les faire à courte vue le fascisme
leur accord avec les pratiques des
antilles faa ou avec des tâches les
antifas et même dans votre doctrine il
ya cette idée sur laquelle il faut
mettre à bas le capitalisme
d'accord il faut mettre en place donc
d'autres d'autres ça me semble tout à
fait libre oui c'est évident mais ce
n'est pas évident pour nous de mettre ma
balle capitalisme il est très utilisé
transformer la société générale est le
terreau bruits et urée drucker avec le
capitalisme pour vous fait valoir
société et vous faites quoi vous devez
donc mettre un état puissant pour
empêcher tous les capitalistes de
vouloir faire fructifier ce qu'ils
veulent bien faire fructifier on voit
remettre à bas le point fondamental vous
cité qu'est la propriété privée et je
pense que la base c'est de respecter la
propriété privée que le tag la
pulvérisation violente vous appelez ça
violence matérielle des vitrines les
gens ne sont pas remboursés vous avez
des gens qui font faillite des gens qui
se suicident par la suite tout ceci est
insupportable il ya deux écoles il ya
ceux qui vont dire oui bon c'est petit
violence matérielle on est là pour faire
la révolution il ya les gens les gens
celui qui estime que la façon dont se
conduisent ces mouvements sociaux est
aujourd'hui insupportable je le fais par
anecdote j'ai toujours adoré les manifs
personnellement j'habite dans le 11e et
je suis ravi depuis des années de
pouvoir suivre participé à plein de
manifestations j'ai emmené mes enfants
par avant le 1er mai c'était formidable
et des ballons etc etc ça ne dégénère
est jamais ou presque sauf dernière des
balles et des bannières particulière
d'éléments incontrôlés qui n'est pas la
bannière d'ailleurs éléments incontrôlés
aujourd'hui ça me fait tout le temps ça
peut être tout le temps parce que la
police fait parce que des manifestations
entre le matin c'est pas mon avis ces
nouvelles observations
vous avez observé des manifestations de
manière systématique ouais bien sûr
c'est marrant parce qu'il ya eu déjà eu
pour le coup des journalistes qu'ils
l'ont fait ii y compris du monde mais
aussi de mediapart qui n'ont pas du tout
montré ce genre de jean charest veut pas
sur des manifestations précise sur sur
par exemple la nasse qui avait été
organisée place d'italie pour là il me
semble anniversaire du mouvement des
jaunes sur une manifestation décembre
dernier qui avait commencé à à porte des
lilas mediapart a fait une enquête très
précise sur cette manifestation là c'est
pas du tout que les arrestations en
france ne dégénère pas plus
systématiquement dans la violence
aujourd'hui c'est nier une réalité à
jeudi qu'elle dégénère en grande partie
du fait de la doctrine et des pratiques
de maintien de l'ordre la porte voix ld
et les nerfs parce que à l'intérieur il
ya des gens qui veulent tout casser si
vous mettez les gens dans les nasses il
est pas obligés qu'ils cassent les nokia
15 20 ans y avait pas de personne qui
voulait tout casser qui voulait tout
casser probablement mais cachez moi
alors je poserai l'autre kettering cas
c'est moi c'est tout je poserai il ya
six mois il ya eu moins de voitures qui
brûlaient y ait moins de vitrines
explosées il ya moins de gens qui
étaient blessés mais en de gâter la
casse qui est très clair c'est où va
votre solidarité dans cette affaire moi
je suis pour la poule entre la police et
un garant de l'ordre social vous avez
tout à fait le droit de vouloir
maintenir cet ordre et il est du coup
l'organe dont c'est la fonction mais
effectivement moi du coup dans cette
affaire ma solidarité spontanément irait
plutôt aux personnes mutilées et aux
personnes qui ont été tuées par la
police au cours des 40 dernières années
plutôt qu'à quelques vitrines qui ont
été tagués mais c'est ok c'est votre
jour il avait aussi la vo comme
d'habitude chacun des accusés de
caricaturer l'autre
non mais je n'aime pas l'expression
grèce ou s'il y en a un je pense que on
peut tous avoir de la compassion pour
tout ce qui s'est passé et pour les
erreurs de la police pour des problèmes
de doctrine comme de réalisation
concrète de violence etc après dans la
balance vous amenez vos 700 morts dans
les quartiers que vous allez dire
populaire ou sensibles dire que c'est de
la faute de la police que ça n'a pas été
incriminé était alors que les inspection
générale de la police nationale
l'inspection générale de la gendarmerie
nationale un corps 0,10 à vue sont des
cordes la police we meet comme ça vient
des tarifs des taillis ce n'est pas un
organe indépendant que ce qui somme les
1eres comme le cnrs qui vous paye est un
organe de l'état alors et donc vous avez
strictement aucune indépendance et vous
êtes payé par l'état pour dire ce que
vous êtes en train de dire je sais pas
dépendants au sein des grandes
organisations je voudrais pour avancer
de savoir comment on peut s'y lie à
processus de facilitation et il faut et
je pense qu'il faut toujours se poser la
question être vigilant c'est déjà arrivé
ça ça peut arriver dans d'autres pays
que le nôtre et ça peut aussi arriver
dans le nôtre comment s'y prendre ce
qu'il faut défendre la démocratie est ce
qu'il faut défendre l'état de droit est
ce qu'il faut défendre les libertés vous
vous le dites et je reprends ce que
disait julien il faut une rupture avec
le capitalisme a dit vous et il faut la
demande à pouvoir populaire
j'ai l'impression que vous faites
allusion à la dictature du prolétariat
et je me dis bon c'est un fascisme pour
un autre ou quoi on n'emploie pas cette
expression et on en est loin mais on
aura est en eux l'emploi est pas un mais
est-ce que ça dépasse à l'avènement d'un
pouvoir populaire et la rupture avec le
capitalisme ça donne l'a dit et c'est là
la définition étymologique de la
démocratie c'est pouvoir du peuple
pouvoir du peuple par le peuple pour le
peuple et effectivement on insiste sur
le fait que dans les démocraties ont
même libéral mais dont on sait déjà ce
et douaniers la démocratie dans laquelle
on vit qui n'est pas très libérale la
place du parlement est très secondaire
les libertés sont rognées et c'est bon
on est plutôt dans des démocraties
d'ailleurs il libéral en france un bon
mais bon du coup et
et puis
c'est qu'on défend c'est une conception
plus substantielle de la démocratie
c'est comment on fait pour retrouver la
définition authentique d'une hémorragie
pouvoir populaire est effectivement une
des thèses qu'on défend mais qui est
très classique c'est que il est
absolument inconcevable d'avoir une
démocratie réelle tant que disons les
ressources productives d'une société ce
qu'on appelait antérieurement expression
peu vieillotte mais les moyens de
production sont aux mains d'une toute
petite minorité qui décide pour tout le
monde et qui décide par exemple un jour
de délocaliser parce que eh bien la
rentabilité de leur capital serait
meilleur et bien en europe de l'est etc
et qui laisse sur le carreau des
milliers de deux ouvriers de famille
voilà donc nous effectivement la
démocratie plus substantielles que dans
ton que l'on défend dans ce livre c'est
une démocratie dans lequel la majorité
de la population a le contrôle y compris
de l'économie donc effectivement c'est
quelque chose qui va non seulement à
l'encontre de la démocratie libérale
mais évidemment à l'encontre des projets
néo fasciste qui n'ont pas du tout cette
ambition là bon alors je voulais
vraiment disent que ça que les projets
néo fasciste qui les incarnent
maintenant vous dites bien que il
faudrait que la majorité de la
population puisse
dx compose des autres c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui pas du tout bien sûr il
deuxième chose si la majorité de la
population n'est pas d'accord avec votre
projet qu'est ce que vous faites
nous nous espérons en tout cas ludivine
vente signés moi ça ne sommes que deux
bons anges en inspire pas un coup de
force d'ailleurs vous avez remarqué on
n'appelle pas un coup de force
d'ailleurs ce qui à ce qu'ils appellent
à un coup de force dans l'année dans la
conjoncture présente c'est plutôt des
militaires c'est plus beau il ya eu des
tribunes qui disait il face au
délitement de la france face aux hordes
de banlieue reprenant tel ou tel quel
tout le discours bricks and what il faut
une réaction et on sentait que ce à quoi
ils appelaient c'était une forme de coup
de force et donc un homme fort et c'est
bon
c'est je ne vois pas pourquoi vous nous
associer à ce type de chose alors que
parce que précisément nous nous à nous
appelons à une démocratisation beaucoup
plus avancé d'une sérieux mr que les
sociétés que les sociétés dans
lesquelles nous vivons actuellement non
mais tout le monde est d'accord pour
qu'ils aient plus de pouvoir pour chacun
des individus et qu'on ne soit pas sous
le carcan d'un état ultra présent et
c'est avec moi je suis très libérale à
ce que ces néo libérale et méchant
pourquoi pas que je dirais c'est que
d'abord moi ce qui me semble être la
pointe avancée du fascisme c'est lorsque
nous avions ces images de gilet jaune
qui courait vers l'elysée pour prendre
le pouvoir d'accord qui me semble être
la pointe avancée d'un régime
autoritaire c'est qu'andré gens en noir
fait tout pour faire valoir leurs idées
qui sont extrêmement minoritaires alors
après ça vous pouvez trouver des
généraux qui nous disent des choses mais
quel rapport avec le livre c'est ce que
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure pour nous
dire que dans les manifestations il ya
des louis jeux d'eau que j'ai dit qu'il
fallait faire ça non voulues les
nouveaux maîtres il faut mettre fin à la
propriété des privée des moyens de
production oui alors dans le sens de
tous ceux qui de manière assez radicale
vous voyez ça faisait déjà des jaunes en
allant à l'assaut de lennon les deux
parties dès mardi des gens qui incarne
la gauche radicale c'est ce qu'il
souhaite faire là le côté nuit debout on
papote et c'est assez formidable et il
ya le côté nuit debout avancé où on
attaque je pense que ce sont ceux là les
gens dangereux après ça il élit gilet
jaune je pense qu'il est logiquement
c'est très divers c'est peut-être mieux
beaucoup mieux que moi après ça
j'observe dans la rue c'est que c'est
pas la police et l'armée qui sont en
train de se parachuter pour prendre le
pouvoir mais qu'il y ait des mouvements
de sédition concrets pour tenter de
prendre le pouvoir et ses palais
les chroniques ou les tribunes dans
valeurs actuelles qui me font peur mais
c'est plutôt ça est ce que je pourrais
poser la question d'une autre manière
c'est qu'au fond on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui tous les bords veulent
nous a posé des menus une mesure
autoritaire on peut le dire et certains
ne s'en privent pas de l'extrême droite
comme on peut le dire et certains ne
s'en privent pas de l'extrême gauche
mais on pourrait dire aussi des
écologistes des gilet jaune de l ère de
l hérault m des féministes des vegan
j'ai l'impression que les mesures
autoritaires c'est le nouveau mouvement
mode
je sais pas quoi vous faites référence
il ya les écologistes de pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
veulent des mesures autoritaires sinon
il y aura pas d autres moyens la
démesure des mini j par exemple si pas
des mesures autoritaires folle encore
faut s'entendre si par exemple on dit le
problème c'est les combustibles fossiles
c'est le capital fossiles il faut par
exemple reconvertir toute cette
industrie pour faire autrement produire
autrement produire - sans doute
d'ailleurs il faut arrêter de projet de
jeu on va vous interdit de prendre
l'avion par ailleurs elle a sans doute
qu'il faut qu'il y ait des gens qui
prennent beaucoup moins d'avions que ce
qu'ils font aujourd'hui c'est que jamais
dans les milieux autoritaire oui bon ce
sont des mesures autoritaires qui vit
qui vise effectivement à arrêt du gant
par exemple il faut réduire je sais pas
le nombre de super yachts dans la
windsor voilà le surnom d' interdit les
sucres et la question c'est toujours
c'est pas tellement ce sont
effectivement des incursions assez
autoritaire par dans la propriété privée
ça c'est évident et et voilà et on y on
est je crois qu on n'y échappera pas si
on aspire effectivement une
transformation sociale et ongles à
l'admission qu'aujourd'hui c'est comme
si vous reprenez il ya 30 ou 40 ans
beaucoup moins ils s'insurgent enfermer
les gens qui ont un super yacht menace
est choyé voyage mais il ya quand même
une différence quand il se dire qu'il ya
30 40 ans on avait été moins porté sur
les mesures de restriction de liberté là
où c'est de ce type de mesures
autoritaires ce qui est de la crise
environnementale c'est que la crise
environnementale n'était pas ce qu'elle
est et ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui effectivement la situation
est à ce point grave et le rapport du
giec de l'été l'a encore rappelé que
effectivement on ne coupera pas un
certain nombre de mesures qui seront
autoritaire vis-à-vis de ceux qui sont
les plus riches et y compris vis-à-vis
des grandes entreprises qui imposeront
des transitions dans les industries les
plus polluantes
on n'y échappera pas sincèrement sinon
on va à la catastrophe on le sait déjà
et là encore c'est pas l'extrême gauche
les autonomes les black blocks les
antifas qui raconte ça ce sont des
institutions qui ont pignon sur rue et
des experts c'est ce que je vais dire
c'est que la menace fasciste dont vous
parlez dans votre livre on pourrait se
dire mais qu'elle vient de tous bords
cette menace fasciste de tous les bords
est-ce que fascisme n'est pas un simple
synonyme d' autoritarisme fascisme c'est
un certain type de projet vous dit que
vous aviez reçu externe est un très très
beau très belle entretient d'ailleurs
sur la vigilance nécessaire sur la
renaissance du fascisme et que le
fascisme n'est pas n'a pas disparu dans
l'est dans les ruines de berlin en 45 ce
qui me dit souvent il a raison le
fascisme a réémergé sous forme de projet
politique au moment de la grande crise
du première grande crise du capitalisme
dans les 70 80 en tout cas dans certains
pays et il a essayé développer à nouveau
à partir de là crise de 2008 donc et il
montrait dans cette émission avant sa
mort puisqu'il disparue il montrait des
photos de ce qu'ils considéraient comme
les fascistes d'aujourd'hui parmi
lesquels il y avait d'ailleurs benyamin
nétanyahou metalor est éternel et
citoyenne israël et si on si on suit
sternhell le fascisme c'est un certain
type de projet politique et la violence
que prône le fascisme est que pratiquent
les groupuscules fascistes etc vise les
groupes opprimés les minorités en
général les femmes les femmes quand
elles s'organisent pour leurs droits et
leurs intérêts et ses
organismes pour leur droit les attaques
les féministes ont été régulièrement
attaqué y compris des personnes lgbt
encore encore au début de l'année quand
il ya des manifestations dans de très
nombreuses villes des groupuscules
identitaires
ou bien
envoyer un type en train de 2 lire une
lettre d'amour à une mini sommet parle
alors de quoi parlez-vous je râle dans
la corrèze notre impression que sont les
adresses e mail m'annonçant que le wali
la populace vous renseigne horaire je
vous fais beaucoup vous savez j'avais
besoin qu'on me 1,8 à me renseigner je
le dis je c'est avoir des pateras de
nous parler des violations des droits de
l'homme je ne lis pas que valeurs
actuelles je lit plein de choses mais
votre avis là bon vous et à l'intérêt de
tout cela je note que vous nous dites
qu'il de la région georges du fascisme
il ya plein de groupuscules qui
attaqueraient tout le monde etc il n'y a
jamais eu le temps de droit a affirmé
est de plus en plus accès à l'endroit
des pour les homosexuels pour les femmes
etc et c'est formidable
voici des ratios ni backlash si vous
voulez mais il n'est rien par rapport à
la tendance générale qui est sûr
quelques décennies la transformation
considérable vers plus de tolérance de
la société française donc de là à élire
dans ces bacs lâche un retour du
fascisme je pense que c'est une menace
fantôme vous nous parler de la menace
fasciste c'est plutôt un titre de la
guerre des étoiles que vous devriez
trouver c'est une menace fantôme en tout
cas vous pourrez aller vérifier il ya il
ya eu une régulièrement des attaques
très violentes de manifestations
féministes ou lgbt cuit notamment au
début de l'année en janvier allez
vérifier donc ces cépages et de vérifier
tous et ne voudrais pas me citer
toujours pareil de s'envoyer le dira les
vérifions ces départs mythique qu'est ce
qui est le plus violent aujourd'hui
c'est des groupuscules d'extrême droite
ils vont taper de temps en temps peut
être radicalement sur les manifestations
je prends trop quoi lgbt cube et y est
c'est tout ce que vous voudrez pardon
pour le brin d'ironie mais il faut
sourire de tout cela parfois ou est ce
que c'est le fait que la société
française si je dis sans sauvageonne
d'aller dire assez scandaleux c'est
d'une valeur actuelle dans le texte mais
est fait de plus en plus de ce que c'est
c'est issus des 2 délivre d'un idéologue
identitaire laurent oberto wings citerne
de belles pages à lorient mais d'autres
hélas si vous voulez emprunter nous on
se réfère par exemple à aimé césaire qui
est l'inventeur de cette formule qui
parle de l'ensauvagement du continent
bon mon sujet c'est que les violences et
les violences radicale la volonté de
mettre en place un système plus
autoritaire en france c'est plutôt de
l'islamo fascisme qui est aussi un
néologisme qui va pas vous plaire qui
est pas critiquer dans votre lit puisque
vous critiquer celui d' islam au
gauchisme islamo fascistes vous devez
pas l'apprécier
grandement aussi les violences à l'égard
des femmes de mon point de vue c'est les
violences plutôt du côté d'une partie de
ceux qui en france veut la loi spear à
faire des attentats à faire une mise au
pas de la population des faits avant
particuliers et des minorités et à
mettre en place des théocraties ça ça me
semble dangereux bien plus que le
fantasme de groupuscules qui parfois
sont délirants parfois peuvent être
localement dangereux mais qui ne
représente pas grand chose par rapport à
cette autre menace bien plus
préoccupants je suis les violences
faites aux femmes en france c'est le
fait de deux groupes qui veulent imposer
une théocratie lens a milk sea pas
exactement ce que j'ai dit si vous me
suivez vous avez dit qu il y avait dans
ces violences s'est partie de la
population qui les incarnent toutes les
couches de la population sont
représentées dans les violences faites
aux femmes dans l'est dans les violences
sexistes et sexuelles il ya un roc un
groupe qui échappent malheureuse et
entraînement ouais et alors on va
prendre le sujet du terrorisme alors et
là il ya aucun groupe qui est différent
des autres la violence des terroristes
est aujourd'hui les actes terroristes
c'est l'extrême droite c'est le fascisme
ces générations identitaire ses valeurs
échelle sans évoquer l'extrême droite et
les développeurs de la fra ordinateur
est toujours le sujet de dire ah bah oui
les attentats islamistes tuent d'abord
des musulmans c'est incontestable dans
le monde et cette idée dans la série
parce que l'ambiance n'est pas le cas
c'est parce que jeudi par contre en
europe et si vous pouvez inclure aussi
le si on veut parler du monde occidental
l'extrême droite et au premier rang du
en termes de nombre de nombre
d'attentats mais très vite je vous parle
de la france l'a aujourd'hui c'est pas
du défenseur des dogues en temps il ya
eu le temps d'y aller
tout ceci on peut faire trois constats
l'extrême droite y surveiller deuxième
chose à l'échelle du monde peut-être
jean sérien l'extrême droite attaque
tout le monde et c'est terrible
troisième chose aujourd'hui de
terrorizer et se décalera quelqu'un a vu
les choses que j'avais une centaine de
musulmans d'anvers en nouvelle-zélande
mais également de militants de gauche en
en or vert et début des années 2010
quant à l'extrême mais à chaque fois ce
sont les attentes à quoi j'ai qui ont
tué des dizaines de personnes mais je
vous parle pas des attentats d'ea bougez
vous disiez que les habitants étaient
présents d'abord dans les deux congo
l'arsla de mon avis une forme de
fascisme qui est le fascisme
théocratique des forces musulmanes
intégristes qui en france pose problème
on n'ouvre pas aujourd'hui un des procès
les plus retentissants à venir et les
plus importants pour se cacher les yeux
se dire ah non la violence c'est
l'extrême droite en france ça n'est pas
vrai bah là vraiment c'est aussi les 100
watts et vient voix il ya plein de
choses comme ça après quelques instants
il ya la gloria du whisky il ya plein de
choses mais qu'il vous dirais qu'il ya
des attentats djihadistes en france j'ai
mon nous avons signé ce fait là dans le
nord ne lui n'y est pas c'est très bien
mais vous êtes en train de dire
attention à la violence d'extrême droite
et second reste que le projet calais
secondes pour revenir sur le débat c'est
parce qu'on parle d' autoritarisme
d'audience le en fait si on veut
comprendre ce qu'est le projet fasciste
il faut effectivement voir que c'est une
sont des forces politiques qui visent un
usage très intensif y ait de la violence
par rapport à ce à quoi nous sommes
accoutumés mais harry mais un certain
type de projet politique qui vise à à
mettre au pas les minorités alors
c'étaient les juifs les minorités
ethnoraciales et minorités religieuses
s'étaient majoritairement les juifs qui
étaient visés par l'extrême orient 1
dans la première moitié de cela
aujourd'hui personnes à bord alors qu'il
qualifie politique a écrit je vais
mettre au pas c'est une petite minorité
à bas la mise au pas des musulmans en
france c'est effectivement au programme
du front national lui dire c'est au
programme des lycées les sept oeuvres
exotique il m'a par exemple le fait d'un
de leurs dons ont parlé des libertés
publiques la liberté de porter un signe
religieux par exemple marie-hélène nous
dit j'interdirais dans tous les lieux
publics donc dans la rue par exemple
bondi début mai mais j'arrivais à tous
les signes religieux donc par rapport à
ça c'est pas faux je t'accorde avoir
entendu oui oui donc c'est passé
revisité tous les services outils pour
elle oui monsieur mais très bien ça fait
partie pour elle ça ça ne trompe
personne pourquoi mais ça démontre celle
d'ailleurs quand elle le présente devant
jerrada maintenant pendant le débat est
dit je vais faire un je vais demander un
sacrifice à nos concitoyens juifs mais
enfin en réalité ils savent très bien
que ce sont les musulmans donc
séparatistes communautariste etc mettez
de brocchi mais qui sont visés ceux là
encore on va pas se raconter d'histoires
ce sont eux et elles qui sont visés dans
le débat public français depuis une
vingtaine d'années comme étant coupable
de ne pas vouloir s'intégrer de de vivre
en communauté et c'est bon mais nos
concitoyens musulmans ainsi que les
immigrés musulmans considérer qu'ils
sont moins ou mieux traités qui lient à
10 15 20 30 40 ans je veux pas entendre
votre réponse avant de donner ma
position ils sont beaucoup mieux traité
15 secondes se répondent sur quelle base
vous pouvez dire ça parce que par
exemple ya déjà des enquêtes d'ailleurs
dans le cas de l'institut montaigne
auxquels vous participez il montre de
très très fortes discriminations les
variations dit vous ne pouvez pas dire
qu'il y en a - aujourd'hui qui en avait
il ya dix ans les accès au marché du
travail a pas de comparaison dans le
passé et enfin il ya parfois mais bien
le droit c'est du droit qui s'est
transformé le droit aujourd'hui leur
permet beaucoup plus que ce qu'ils
pouvaient auparavant - on se
fera sur cette interrogation
je vous remercie d'avoir participé à ce
débat tous les deux je vous remercie de
l'avoir suivi et je vous donne
rendez-vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
non